bonjour à tous merci d'être venus
nombreux pour cette convention pour
l'éducation et merci annie genevard pour
cette organisation qui nous impose un
rythme soutenu cette troisième table
ronde est consacrée à la réussite de
l'élève
c'est un très grand projet ça ne peut
pas être simplement une déclaration ou
une incantation
il faut que ce soit aussi une réalité
nous ne serons pas exhaustif dans cette
table ronde mais par contre nous allons
essayer d'illustrer cette réussite de
l'élève au travers des trois missions du
service public de l'éducation nationale
c'est à dire instruire et éduquer et
inséré professionnellement je vais
d'abord passer la parole monsieur le
principal de collège du doubs qui est
également vice président du conseil
départemental du doubs sur ce sujet qui
fait aujourd'hui couler beaucoup
d'encrés et de mots celui de la réforme
du collège peut-il y avoir réussite de
l'élève avec la réforme du collège est
telle qu'elle est prévue
c'est un des grands sujets avec les
rythmes scolaires sur la réforme du
collège vous l'avez entendu les
critiques sont nombreuses
notre proposition serait plutôt de
l'abrogation de cette réforme dont dans
tout état de cause on ne peut penser
qu'elle ne s'appliquera contre la
volonté des enseignants contre la
volonté des parents monsieur fagots je
vous donne la parole sur ce sujet après
quelques bouts de présentation merci
merci beaucoup donc effectivement les ou
que ludovic magaud principal donc de
deux établissements qui sont en réseau
donc dans le département du doubs et
vice président du conseil départemental
donc concernant la réforme du collège
quand elle nous est arrivé dans nos
établissements scolaires je ne sais pas
si
ils ont été plusieurs en tout cas à
réfléchir sur cette réforme est en tout
cas je serais très curieux de pouvoir
les rencontrer pour pouvoir échanger
avec eux puisque c'est vrai que ça nous
interpelle énormément ça nous interpelle
énormément concernant déjà la forme la
forme puisque c'est quand même quelque
chose de très descendants c'est une
réforme qui nous est imposée qui arrive
comme ça brutalement dans les
établissements scolaires et on sait très
bien que toutes choses brutales qui
arrive comme ça dans nos établissements
scolaires c'est toujours complexe en
tout cas à mettre à mettre en place
ensuite il ya le font vraiment de la
réforme et j'aurai trois interventions
sur ce fond on nous parle dans le cadre
de la mise en place de la réforme
d'égalité des chances mais pour moi
quand il y à égalité des chances c'est
qu'on veut pouvoir permettre en tout cas
aux élèves de pouvoir évoluer et de
pouvoir avoir de l'ambition est en tout
cas progresser en tout cas cette réforme
je ne la traiteraient pas d'égalité des
chances mais je la traiterait plutôt sur
la base de l'égalitarisme de
l'égalitarisme pourquoi parceque il me
semble qu'elle enferme en tout cas les
élèves dans un cadre unique
c'est la même chose pour tout le monde
et j'y reviendrai par la suite elle
neutralise aussi l'ambition des élèves
elle neutralise également leurs
possibilités d'évolution et elle nivelle
par le bas et pourquoi elle nivelle par
le bas j'en veux pour preuve puisque on
supprime tout ce qui marchait jusqu'à
maintenant c'est à dire que les classes
bilangues qui marchait on les supprime
le latin ne devient même pas un
enseignant un enseignement de complément
il devient un enseignement
complémentaire
ça a été traité juste auparavant on
supprime également les classes à option
c'est à dire les sections européennes
qui fonctionnait là où les élèves
étaient motivés en tout cas à entrer
dans ces sections là on le supprime donc
en fin de compte on est vraiment sur
cette suppression et c'est pour ça que
moi je parle d'égalitarisme et je dirais
presque à dire qu on est quasiment sûr
une paupérisation en tout cas du niveau
collège avec la mise en place de cette
de cette réforme
et puis en fait on supprime tout
simplement on va dire des
diversifications qui étaient présentes
au sein de l'école dont on a tant besoin
est là en fin de compte on renferme
alors je ne sais pas si c'est vraiment
symptomatique
du gouvernement du gouvernement
actuellement en tout cas ce refus de
l'ambition et ce refus de l'excellence
est vraiment très compliqué surtout
quand on met régulièrement en avant que
les élèves doivent être dans des
parcours là on ne met pas les élèves
dans des parcours on les a en faire
vraiment dans des cases fermé et on sort
vraiment et on exclut vraiment cette
personnalisation en tout cas de du
collège en tout cas par la mise en place
de cette réforme
le deuxième point va bien sûr sur
l'affaiblissement des disciplines on va
affaiblir les disciplines on en a parlé
précédemment avec le latin ans j'en veux
pour preuve puisque le latin été étudiés
donc dès la classe de 5e un élève qui
faisaient du latin de la 5ème jusqu'à la
troisième avec 280 heures avec
maintenant s'il devient un enseignement
complémentaire c'est à dire que même les
lèvres n'est pas forcée d'aller dedans
c'est à dire qu'il faudra qu'il ait vécu
auparavant un enseignement pratique
interdisciplinaire de langues et
cultures de l'antiquité il n'en fera que
180 heures de latin donc c'est à dire
qu'on perd senteurs aussi sur sur le
latin mais j'en veux aussi sur les
bilangue dire qu'un élève qui rentrait
en classe bilangue en sixième allez
vivre durant toute sa scolarité de
collèges 430 heures et avec maintenant
l'introduction de la lv2 en cinquième il
n'en fera que 279 qui va perdre 160
heures sur les classes bilangues ou en
tout cas notamment sur la lv2 mais je
pourrais venir aussi sur d'autres
options que ce soit la découverte
professionnelle 3 heures ou autres
l'autre parcours qui existait au sein de
l'établissement
les deux pays donc nos fameuses
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire c'est quelque chose
de très nébuleux de très troublant huit
thématiques qui sont imposés ne s'est
pas trop d'où elles sortent avec
derrière pas de contenu ou les
enseignants ne sont pas du tout préparés
ne sont pas du tout préparés à
travailler ensemble dans le cadre de la
mise en place de ces de ces deux pays et
puis surtout sur quelle périodicité
ces deux pays vont pouvoir vont être
faits on ne le sait pas donc en bon
représentant de l'état en tant que chef
d'établissement
on le met en place puisqu'il va falloir
que ça se met en place pour la rentrée
de septembre 2016 mais je ne vous cache
pas que dans les établissements
scolaires c'est très complexe puisque
les enseignants ne sont pas du tout
préparé
à travailler aussi ensemble pour
certains parce qu'on ne peut pas non
plus imposer à certains enseignants il
ya certaines disciplines de travailler
ensemble
c'est aussi complexe et puis par rapport
à l'affaiblissement donc des disciplines
les enseignements notamment de
mathématiques et de lettres vont devoir
aussi prendre de leur temps
disciplinaire pour intervenir dans le
cadre des deux pays et donc ça se fait
vraiment au détriment vraiment des
fondamentaux que sont la langue le
français les mathématiques ou ou
l'anglais notamment pour ne parler que
de ces trois disciplines
autre contrainte et celle là qui est
très complexe
c'est qu'on a mis une certaine équité au
niveau des horaires ses 26 heures pour
tout le monde de la 6e à la 3e donc ses
26 heures donc hebdomadaire la liberté
j'ai bien apprécié les propos de
monsieur le recteur tout à l'heure où le
chef d'établissement sans vie sont
établies à son établissement en fonction
de certains indicateurs
effectivement on peut se rencontrent
qu'une cohorte d'élèves à un besoin
supplémentaire d'avoir une demi-heure
semaine ou une heure quinzaine donc en
lettres ou en maths en fonction de cette
cohorte qui arrive on aura même pas la
possibilité de le faire c'est à dire
qu'on est enfermé dans 26 eur 26 heures
par classe donc on est sur du
saupoudrage d'heure avec les moyens qui
ne sont qui nous sont données et le
troisième volet que je voulais exprimer
devant vous aujourd'hui concernent
vraiment cette réforme qui est
discriminante pour l'ensemble des
établissements et j'en veux pour preuve
avec mon expérience puisque je suis
principal de deux établissements en
réseau qui présente la même structure
j'ai exactement le même nombre de
classes dans mon établissement donc d'un
côté et le même nombre de classes dans
mon établissement donc de l'autre et
pourtant dans mes moyens qui sont à
louer j'ai un écart de 22 heures
hebdomadaires
j'ai un écart de 22 heures hebdomadaires
qui est justifié apparemment en fonction
du nombre d'élèves par division qui me
sont alloués mais je ne peux même pas
utiliser ces 22 heures en fonction de la
spécificité de mon établissement et en
fonction des besoins de mes élèves
puisque je suis contre un don
avec 6 26 heures hebdomadaires dans
laquelle donc nous nous sommes enfermés
avec avec cette loi et que cette réforme
donc nous sommes vraiment sur une
réforme à deux vitesses dans nos
établissements scolaires et dans nos
collèges et sur une inégalité de
traitement en tout cas par rapport aux
dotations qui sont alloués donc pour
pour conclure on nous fait croire en
tout cas que nous sommes vraiment dans
la mise en place de parcours donc au
service de la réussite des élèves pas du
tout pas du tout on est vraiment sur un
cadre qui enferme les élèves où on
empêche les élèves vraiment de d'évoluer
et d'avoir de l'ambition avec la
suppression de tout ce qui marchait
jusqu'à 1 jusqu'à maintenant on
affaiblit les disciplines en tout cas
qui nous paraissent enfin l'euro tout
cas où elles doivent a en tout cas aller
sur c'est sur ces deux pays et puis on
enlève en tout cas de l'autonomie en
matière en matière de gestion pour les
établissements et pour les chefs
d'établissement juste une petite
anecdote sur sur un collège j'ai une
moyenne de 29 élèves par classe les
moyens qu'ils mettaient en quatrième les
moyens qui m'était donnée dans le cadre
de ma préparation de rentrée je pouvais
dégager des moyens pour créer une classe
supplémentaire pour alléger mes
effectifs en quatrième cela m'a été
refusé pour garder vraiment la structure
qui avait été construite au démarrage
par par le rectorat et surtout aussi
pour ne pas diluer en tout cas comme il
pouvait me le dire les moyens alors que
ça allait à l'encontre part en tout cas
vous allez dans le sens d'une vraie
politique d'établissement par rapport à
des besoins identifiés
donc voila un petit peu pour vous dire
certaines choses j'ai été aussi très
attentifs à certains propos qui ont pu
être tenus sur sur les ondes et j'ai
bien aimé la remarque de luc ferry qui
disait un moment donné sur la réforme
que le nouveau remplacé l'important est
effectivement tout ce qui est important
est en train de disparaître et je crois
qu'il serait en tout cas de notre sens
en tant que républicain et j'ai été très
très agréablement en tout cas apprécié
les propos qui ont été tenus ce matin
il faut vraiment que l'on revienne aux
fondamentaux qui font vraiment aussi la
force de notre système éducatif
merci monsieur fagots pour votre
témoignage voir ce que vous vivez seul
attrait concrètement sur ses
propositions qui sont faites pour la
rentrée elles font écho aux propos de
notre collègue député frédéric reiss qui
intervenait tout à l'heure et qui a posé
hier une question d'actualité à madame
la ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
n'a toujours aucun doute sur le bien
fondé de sa réforme puisque elle partait
de cette idée que les enfants s'ennuient
y est au collège et qu'il fallait donc
leur trouver des possibilités de
d'intérêt très diversifié je crois que
vous avez rappelé ce qui était essentiel
de cette formation pendant ces quatre
années de collège mais pour le moment
malgré l'opposition des enseignants et
c'est ce qui a été rappelé la faible
participation à toutes les formations
qui sont organisées cette contestation
sur le bien fondé de cette réforme
l'opposition des parents aussi qui se
rendent bien compte de l'appauvrissement
de l'exigence au collège de
l'appauvrissement matière de contenu eh
bien je crois qu'elle reste convaincu du
bien fondé de l'ensemble des dispositifs
qu'elle le crès également de créer plus
d'égalité comme vous l'avez dit cela
ressemble plus à de l'égalitarisme parce
que je crois que l'on inscrit avec cette
réforme beaucoup plus de d'inégalités
que l'on ne résout de questions de
moyens ou de
deux réponses appropriées pour pour les
collégiens et futures et futurs
collégiens
merci pour votre témoignage et merci
pour votre engagement au service des
élèves de collège
nous l'avons dit les trois missions de
l'éducation instruire c'est important la
transmission des connaissances la
transmission aussi des compétences la
mission éduqué il ya donc une importante
mission d'intégration citoyenne pour ce
grand service public de l'éducation
et ce qui est souhaité en termes
d'intégration ce qui est nécessaire va
pouvoir être exposé à trois voix jacques
donc olivier marleix que notre collègue
qui est député d'eure-et-loir et qui est
aux républicains secrétaire national à
l'intégration éric mestrallet qui est
tout au bout du lioran et qui est chef
d'entreprise et qui est président
fondateur de la fondation espérance
banlieue et puis notre collègue
secrétaire national aux républicains qui
est le secrétaire à l'engagement citoyen
à y est
à midi je vous passe dans cet ordre là
où dans l'ordre que vous souhaiterez la
parole sur cette question de
l'intégration citoyenne qui est aussi
une des missions de l'éducation oui
merci merci à dominique
on a beaucoup parlé chez présent
transmission des savoirs évidemment la
première mission de l'école mais depuis
toujours la question de l'école n'est
quand-même consubstantielle à celle de
la transmission aussi des valeurs c'est
tout le débat jean lisa ce matin en
venant la lettre en instituteur de jules
ferry en 1883
depuis le début c'est évidemment tout
l'enjeu tout l'enjeu est aussi de
l'école le constat il est de ce point de
vue assez alarmant dans de nombreux
établissements de nos quartiers
il ya une excellente des seuls onze
ouvrages beaucoup de littérature sur ce
sujet
notamment un ouvrage collectif sur les
territoires perdus de la république qui
est assez assez édifiant fait par un
certain nombre d'enseignants ou un
excédent rapport de notre collègue je
sais pas s'il est encore là mais je l'aï
vu tout à l'heure
jacques grosperrin au sénat qu enfin un
excédent un gros travail de fond sur sur
cette question de la façon dont l'école
dispense aujourd'hui les valeurs de la
république dans les écoles et les
obstacles surtout qu'elles rencontrent
pour y parvenir le constat aujourd'hui
malheureusement sur une grande partie de
notre territoire c'est celui c'est celui
d'un échec est un échec malgré
l'engagement
malgré l'engagement fort des enseignants
notamment parce qu'aujourd'hui ils ont à
faire face à une véritable confrontation
un rapport de force organisée par par
des mouvances islamistes radicales des
témoignages pour compléter tout ce que
je dirai alors ça appelle évidemment de
type de réflexion d'abord une réflexion
sur sur les outils dont l'école doit se
doter pour relever pour relever ces
défis
c'est à dire une école présente un peu
différemment danser dans ces quartiers
donc on va pas à l'encontre évidemment
de l'idéologie du gouvernement
socialiste qui veut de l'égalitarisme à
tous crins partout et même si c'est un
robot de l'intérêt des enfants dansaient
dans ces quartiers ça renvoie la
question convient qu'on a évoqué
largement avec mon style de vie ami ou
un instant même de la question de ces
filières d'excellence dans nos
établissements on se rend compte par
exemple sur un sur un lycée que la
présence d'une classe préparatoire est
automatiquement une source d'une source
de mixité amène d'autres
d'autres élèves à venir fréquenter un
établissement donc c'est important
d'avoir ces filières d'excellence en
lice et c'est important de savoir aussi
en collège c'est toute la question j'ai
pas m'y attarder de cette réforme du
cette réforme du collège qui va
totalement à l'encontre de ce qu'il
faudrait faire dans ces quartiers c'est
la question dans nos quartiers aussi du
lien du lien avec les avec les parents
impliquer les parents dans la danse est
transmission dans cette transmission des
valeurs et là aussi on avait pris une
initiative intéressante avec la loi la
loi ciotti qui impliquait les parents
évidemment que le gouvernement c'est
s'est empressé de supprimer dès qu'il
est arrivé au pouvoir il ya enfin la
question la question des internats
d'excellence qui est une très belle
dynamique qui avait été lancé ce
précédent quinquennat qui aujourd'hui ne
bénéficie plus de la même de la même
ambition pour évoquer aussi rapidement
tout ce qui a été fait dans le cadre des
programmes de réussite éducative qui est
aussi aussi important je crois qu'il ya
un vrai enjeu sur les questions
notamment de soutien scolaire dans ces
quartiers c'est trop souvent
l'utilisation soutien scolaire comme le
faux nez un certain nombre de personnes
pas toujours bien intentionnés en termes
de diffusion des valeurs de la
république et donc je crois aussi que ma
titre personnel ma conviction c'est
qu'il faudrait que ce soutien scolaire
redevienne une sorte de monopole public
dans nos quartiers comme ça quand on a
dit tout ça on a évoqué seulement des
outils
évidemment le sur l'essentiel ce sont
c'est pas les houthis et les objectifs
qu'il faut qu'il faut un signal écoles
et donc c'est vraiment l'idée c'est
vraiment de réinventer de réaffirmer
cette école 17 écoles des valeurs
l'école des valeurs elle passe par part
évidemment d'abord la mission des
enseignants on en a on a parlé
l'enseignant c'est vraiment quelqu'un
qui est un passeur qui est là pour
transmettre une culture
françois-xavier ben ami on a parlé de
manière très brillante pas besoin de pas
besoin de développer ça renvoie un sujet
qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure sur la
formation des enseignants qui évidemment
extrêmement importantes notamment dans
ces quartiers là vous le savez les
règles d'affectation des personnels fait
que ce ne soit pas toujours les
personnels les mieux chevronnés qu'on en
voit dans ce type d'établissement en zep
et puis à même aujourd'hui des lacunes
assez assez effrayante
je pense parfois en plus nos
recrutements de d'enseignants
contractuels danser danser dans ces
établissements non ces collèges jeu il
arrive assez régulièrement qu'on recrute
des individus fichés s comme enseignants
contractuels dans nos établissements
scolaires voilà on a un petit souci
quand même de ce côté là je crois qu'il
faut être un peu plus vigilant il ya la
question fondamentale des programmes
évidemment je crois
je crois que je crois aussi l'utilité du
récit national
je sais pas c'est évoquer avant que
j'arrive mais à l'évidence comment
comment faire aimer la france avec la
description qu'on en fait aujourd'hui
dans nos établissements à travers les
programmes de l'éducation nationale en
présentant notre pays comme étant
l'inventeur de l'esclavagisme ce qui
évidemment totalement faux
l'esclavagisme malheureusement existé de
tout temps dans l'humanité
c'est pas une spécialité française mais
malheureusement on enseigne que ça la
période coloniale et aussi est aussi
enseigné de manière de manière
totalement caricatural
on oublie que les grandes heures de la
période coloniale s'est scellée grandeur
des hussards noirs de la république
qu'il y avait aussi quelque part l'idée
de transmettre de transmettre les
valeurs les valeurs l'esprit des
lumières et les valeurs de la république
donc il ya un vrai travail comment
comment au terme de ses programmes ses
enfants pour est il aimait la france
soit vraiment un mérite personnel
exceptionnel pour y arriver
malgré tout je crois mais je serai ma
voisine de droite en parlent et je crois
aussi beaucoup qu'il faut réintroduire
des rites citoyens dans nos
établissements fondation expérience
beaulieu peut aussi en parler parce que
là on a des on a de vrais d'expérience
tout à fait intéressante
il y à il ya des petits fils un petit
film qui existe qui est formidable sur
lors des cérémonies d'accueil dans la
nationalité française dans la
citoyenneté
je pense qu'à l'école il faut aussi
rediffusé ce type de message je crois en
l'utilité du drapeau à l'école je crois
en l'utilité de l'apprentissage de la
marseillaise si on n'apprend pas à
l'école ces symboles nationaux ou les
apprendra-t-on je prends aussi à la
tenue d' établissements
ben voila je crois qu'il faudra avoir
inventé cette école des valeurs je crois
je sens qu'il faut que j'accélère donc
je continue je conclus on a un sujet on
a un sujet aussi sur lequel il faut
qu'on réfléchisse urgemment le
gouvernement a prévu de le faire c'est
la question des écoles hors contrat
aujourd'hui la question du respect des
valeurs de la république n'est pas
contrôler a priori mais seulement a
posteriori il ya évidemment je crois
urgence urgence à le faire vous aurez
compris moi je suis partisan d'une éco
une école militante mais pas militante
simplement sur des questions de statut
mais militante sur des valeurs de la
république
merci merci olivier pour ce plaidoyer
pour les valeurs de la république et
aussi pour cette invitation à aimer la
france qui est aussi facteur
d'intégration
je donne pour cinq minutes la parole
monsieur mestrallet merci beaucoup de
m'accueillir et de permettre de
présenter ce que paie le terrain ce que
peut faire le terrain ont réponse à tout
ce qui a été évoqué ce matin à la fois
comme constat est aussi comme comme
pistes de solution alors
on l'a identifié ces difficultés l'idée
maintenant c'est comment on peut faire
sauter comment on peut innover avec
beaucoup de pragmatisme c'est ce que la
fondation espérance banlieue fait depuis
2012 donc à l'instar de la création
d'une école à montfermeil dont on a
beaucoup entendu parler qui à laquelle
les médias se sont beaucoup tourné et
qui a commencé à se développer à travers
une école à marseille dans les quartiers
nord et une école à roubaix nicole à
asnières dans les quartiers nord
d'asnières pas confondre avec les
quartiers sud puisqu'il ya deux types de
population très il faut bien les
identifier
et puis aujourd'hui il ya quatre il ya
quatre projets d'école pour la rentrée
de 2016 et une cinquantaine de projets
qui sont à l'étude pour les années à
venir
donc il ya apparemment il ya un besoin
est en effet d'y répondre
donc ça c'est la bonne nouvelle est donc
mon message et dire oui c'est possible
de faire des choses c'est possible il
faut laisser le terrain de faire ils se
donnaient la possibilité au terrain de
pouvoir répondre à ses besoins
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'est ce
qui a été fait sur quels sont les
caisses que ça permet d'illustrer sait
qu'on a une vision très organique de la
communauté éducative et de
l'enseignement qui est fait des petits
effectifs une école une école
professoral une équipe par professeur à
très mobilisés très motivés très liés
c'est pas des instituteurs ou des
posteurs qui interviennent seul c'est
ensemble qu'ils essaient de répondre aux
besoins des enfants
une véritable autonomie du directeur ça
a été évoqué aussi celui qui l'équipe
qui recrute son équipe
l'enseignement des savoirs fondamentaux
ça a été dit je pense que c'est
indispensable
il faut transmettre et c'est bien la
figure du du professeur de l'instituteur
qui est qui est premier au sein de
l'école pour pouvoir donner à aux
enfants la possibilité de progresser il
faut qu'ils aient la possiblité aussi de
l'admirer donc c'est pas qu'une icône
d'un hussard noir c'est aussi la bauxite
et de le rencontrer a trait à d'autres
types d'activités le repas les services
qui sont réalisés au sein de l'école
l'homme qui enseigne est un homme qui
est accessible qu il ya des passions qui
aiment le cinéma le sport
d'ailleurs on peut jouer au foot avec
lui toute âme et c'était prof de
français
ben oui mais ah mais oui mais c'est pas
le procès peut pas faire du sport voilà
on a essayé de bousculer un certain
nombre de codes de règles et je pense
qu'il ya un vrai message dans dans cette
illustration c'est que certes il faut
donner des directives
il faut donner des impulsions
mais surtout de laisser la possibilité
aux terrains de les adapter les mettre
en oeuvre avec une forme de flexibilité
que les décrets de la rue de grenelle ne
permettent pas de d'avoir autre chose
qui est important c'est la participation
et l'engagement des familles l'école
certes éduque et donc où elle contribue
à l'éducation c'est une délégation qui
est fait par les par les familles donc
elle est nécessaire mais on peut pas
laisser la famille à l'écart de l'école
donc on peut pas non plus la laisser
dans l'école donc il ya un juste milieu
évidemment à trouver et c'est important
de les faire adhérer au projet de
l'école et nous nos enfants ne rentrer
dans l'école que si la famille a signé
une charte la charge pédagogique et si
jamais ils ne sont pas d'accord ils ne
sont plus d'accord
eh bien il suffit qu'il parte il ya des
listes d'attentes
donc y'a pas de souci là-dessus et aussi
une proximité avec les familles il avec
les entreprises
on veut que des personnes des personnes
qui travaillent dans l'entreprise vient
de présenter leur métier pour donner
envie aux enfants de se projeter parce
que l'école s'est donné la possibilité
de donner les clés de ce monde adulte
qu'aujourd'hui ces enfants des banlieues
de faim dont les enfants des vendeurs
ont peur et finalement il y rentre à
reculons donc l'école doit permettre à
ces jeunes français de pouvoir
construire leur identité construite de
la société se projeter dans ce monde qui
va demain les accueillir de manière peu
positive alors qu'elle quel résultat
ben on voit des embarquements de jeunes
et de leur famille dans le creuset
de quelle école pour du pays donc c'est
important de le rappeler parce que
finalement tous les ans toutes les
familles toutes les mamans veulent le
meilleur pour leurs enfants
et donc c'est se retrouvent elles
discutent entre elles on voit des liens
qui se font entre communautés on lutte
contre le déterminisme communautaire qui
existe trop dans les banlieues et pour
lequel les professeurs du public et
souvent du privé sont très démunis il
n'y a pas d'accusation de notre passé
ils n'ont pas les outils pour pouvoir
faire donc donc on lutte contre 16,7 ces
éléments là on leur parle de ne pas
avoir peur des gens qui sont différents
d'eux est la première est la première
preuve c'est entre les différentes
communautés donc quand je dis ça c'est
entre les turcs et les marocains tels
qu'on puisse le voir on peut le voir à
m'enfermer par exemple alors une petite
anecdote on emmène les enfants de 3e
préparer leurs brevets dans un petit
stage à la campagne pour qu'il découvre
la nature qu'il rencontre le réel etc ou
fois ils n'ont jamais quitté leur leur
cité et on leur mène désormais devoir
aussi les plages du débarquement parce
que c'est aux problèmes de l'histoire et
ils ont besoin de deux touchés de voir
que c'est pas simplement que dans les
livres et l année dernière il arrive à
la pointe doc il y avait une cérémonie
qui était organisé par une compagnie de
sapeurs pompiers de paris
le capitaine
avait réuni sa compagnie heli une lettre
d'un jeune résistant qui va être fusillé
le lendemain 10 ans cher papa chère
maman je vais être fusillé ne soyez pas
tristes je donne ma vie pour mon pays
c'est important je suis content de le
faire ça permettra à tous ceux qui nous
suivront de pouvoir continuer à être
libre dans ce pays à ce moment là le
petit mohamed qui était là depuis neuf
mois dans l'école dit ben je commence à
comprendre ce que ce que vous enseignez
monsieur le professeur d'histoire que
c'était lui qui était le titulaire de la
croix de la classe de troisième et un
blanc et puis finit par dire et vous
savez cette france là nous on peut
l'aimer
donc ayant fier d'expliquer qui nous
sommes et les lampes l'ensemble des
enfants adhéreront à notre à ce que nous
sommes peut-être avec eux pas une
acceptation complète de tout ce que nous
sommes et retrait il leur compris et ils
pourront y adhérer donc de une école
c'est 120 élèves 150 élèves pas plus
cette vision organique dont je parlais
tout à l'heure ça permet de mobiliser
positivement à peu près 1000 personnes
au tour en comptant les familles tous
les bénévoles qui sont qui sont présents
je pense que 200 écoles fois mille
personnes fait 200 mille personnes on a
créé les anticorps suffisant pour notre
société pour qu'elle puisse se relever
je l'appelle à soutenir notre notre
initiative
moi j'aimerais pu voir la transformer en
cause nationale telle manière à ce que
tout le monde puisse avoir une école
espérance banlieue dans les endroits
difficiles
merci merci merci monsieur mestrallet
pour votre enthousiasme pour votre
initiative mais aussi pour les
réalisations concrètes et peut-être
peut-on s'inspirer d'un certain nombre
des facteurs de réussite pour sinon les
transposer du moins inspiré aussi
certaines évolutions pour terminer sur
cette mission d'éducation et
d'intégration citoyenne je donne la
parole à m aliette hamidi qui est
secrétaire nationale de l'engagement
citoyen merci beaucoup alors je voudrais
remercier eric mestrallet pour le
travail extraordinaire que fait la
fondation banlieue espérances parce que
véritablement vous êtes en train de
sauver des vies et je pèse mes mots et
avec vous vous êtes en train de sauver
peut-être l'avenir de la
france et je crois savoir d'ailleurs qu'
il ya un projet de fonds deux d'école la
fondation banlieue référence au blanc
mesnil dont je suis élu et je pèserai au
maximum pour que ce projet puisse voir
le jour parce que véritablement pour
connaître le travail que vous faites
je trouve cela extraordinaire et de
véritablement de sa lutte et salubrité
publique alors pour continuer d'en faire
pour continuer dans ce témoignage de
terrain parce que beaucoup de choses ont
été dites extrêmement intéressante
depuis ce matin à ces théories voir
vraiment dans l'organisation pratique
des choses et je crois que c'est
important de porter un témoignage parce
que je suis issu des quartiers
populaires et g l'année dernière
mima carrière d'avocate entre
parenthèses pour aller voir ce qui se
passait justement dans les écoles parce
que j'en entendais tellement de choses
que j'y croyais pas vraiment et je suis
assez curieuse et j'aime bien voir les
choses par mes propres yeux donc j'ai eu
cette expérience dans une ville au coeur
de la seine-saint-denis est ce que j ai
découvert est encore plus dramatique que
ce que j'imaginais
la première chose qui m'a vraiment
frappé frappé c'est cette absence en
fait de deux disciplines d'autorité
parce que j'ai fait mon primaire dans
dans le public également
mais il ya vingt ans quand la sonnette
de la récréation sonné tout le monde se
ranger et les professeurs se mettait
dans le vent le rang et on partait en
classe aujourd'hui enfin la sonnette se
met à sonner dans la cour
et puis je vois que personne ce range et
je me dis mais qu'est ce qui se passe et
ce que j'ai eu une hallucination sonore
ou peut-être que c'est pas la bonne ce
n'est donc je pose questions au
professeur d'école qui sont dans la cour
et leur demande mais ce que ça a sonné
ils me répondent oui mais et je demande
donc pourquoi les les élèves ne se range
pas et on me répond oui mais on tape a
prévenu ici c'est le 93 alors là quand
je quand j'ai entendu ça je me suis dit
mais c'est fou quand même parce que on a
intégré
un certain nombre de renoncement sur
cette école alors que c'était ici je
crois qu'il faudrait au maximum
réhabiliter l'autorité et la discipline
j'ai vu également en fait j'ai plein
d'anecdotes mais je vais essayer d'en
sélectionner les plus pertinents par
rapport à tout ce qui a été dit depuis
ce matin on a travaillé j'ai j'avais une
petite section de maternelle donc ces
trois ans et demi et on travaillait sur
l'eau la qualité de l'eau qu'est ce que
à quoi sert l'eau d'où provient l'eau et
j'ai eu cette phrase à ces innocentes de
ma part en dix ans on a beaucoup de
chance en france parce que l'eau est de
bonne qualité dans le robinet et donc
j'ai des enfants de 3 ans et demi c'est
pour vous situer et là j'ai une petite
fille qui me répond oui madame mais moi
mon pays c'est pas la france c'est la
tunisie alors je suis assez étonné mais
bienveillante un toujours des enfants
qu'on a en face de nous et il faut faut
les aider on est là pour les encadrer
alors je pose la question pourquoi est
ce que tu dis que c'est la tunisie parce
que moi mes parents sont initiés ils
sont nés ou en tunisie on voit là on est
tunisien fille oui c'est certes vrai
certainement mais s'ils sont venus en
france c'est certainement parce qu'ils
aiment la france et c'est certainement
parce que ils veulent pour toi un avenir
en france et que tu sois française
alors on commence à travailler sur
qu'est-ce que la france est comme on
faisait un peu ont travaillé sur les
couleurs et sur les formes je décide
dans un atelier de l'après midi de faire
un drapeau de travail sur le drapeau
français donc bleu blanc rouge voilà
tout se passait très bien les enfants
sont très contents et puis quand à la à
la sortie scolaire
quand la directrice voix voit les
enfants qui ressortent tous avec des
dessins comme d'habitude avec un drapeau
français et bien me poser la question
mais qu'est ce que vous sur quoi vous
êtes travail et donc je vous explique ce
qu'il faut savoir que les professeurs
d'école contractuels ne sont pas du tout
cadré
on nous avons nous envoie comme ça dans
la nature enfin tous les ans on nous met
des classes en face de nous sans aucune
formation particulière pédagogie donc
elle vient quand même s'étonner
qu'est ce que vous avez fait donc voilà
je lui explique sûrement de travailler
et me dit oui mais alors moi j'ai un peu
peur de la réaction des parents parce
que je ne sais pas alors voulu m'écouter
quelle que soit la réaction des parents
vous me les envoyer je serai pas leur
répondre et aucun souci sur ça et puis
au final il sait rien
c'est les parents étaient très contents
faut savoir que dans cet établissement
80% des élèves avec des parents qui ne
parlent pas ou qui ne maîtrise pas
correctement le français donc c'est
encore une fois pour vous situer là le
contexte est et en fait je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait une fragilité en
tous les cas une fébrilité intégré là
encore du corps professoral et qui
empêchait ou en tous les cas se retenait
de transmettre tout simplement le
drapeau français ou qu'est-ce que la
france et je crois qu'on est un des
seuls pays au monde où en maternelle ou
en primaire ça peut poser question ça
peut poser problème de travailler sur
sur le drapeau de son pays
alors moi je me dis mais il ya vraiment
un problème de propagande et dans le
sens propagande républicaine et je crois
que l'école c'est trop souvent interdits
et particulièrement dans dans ces
quartiers c'est interdit une propagande
républicaine qui pourtant est nécessaire
c'est à dire qu'elle est attendue
la question c'est pas y at il trop de
cultures étrangères sur nos territoires
et dans ces quartiers populaires la
question c'est est ce qu'on est assez
fort est-ce qu'on est assez puissant est
ce que l'école est assez armée pour
pouvoir transmettre une culture
française qui donne envie et qui donne
envie de à laquelle on donne envie
d'adhérer à ses traits fins et vraiment
centrale et puis un peu plus loin en
primaire on a aussi on l'a dénoncée
depuis ce matin cette idéologie de
l'égalitarisme dans l'éducation
nationale on à moi je suis rentré non
j'ai pris en charge des classes de ce2
par exemple où on y avait des élèves qui
venaient d'arriver de pays étrangers et
qui généralement c'est une tête de plus
que tous les autres et qu'ils ne
maîtrisaient pas le français parce qu'on
peut pas arriver en ce2 et maîtriser le
français et qui du coup comme il était
complètement déracinés déjà de leur
propre pays avec une certaine violence
en plus qu'ils exprimaient à leur façon
en fait on est complètement retardé sur
le programme et moi ça m'est vraiment
sauté aux yeux c'était vraiment flagrant
on est complètement retardé sur le
programme et on retarde dans les autres
parce que l'idéologie voudrait qu'il
faut absolument les intégrer dans des
classes normales et non pas faire des
classes de transition qui puisse les
remettre à niveau et je trouve ça
dramatique parce qu'il y avait des
enfants qui avaient
pour moi un brillant avenir en
mathématiques ou dans d'autres matières
et avec qui je ne pouvais pas avancer ou
tous les mois tout du moins je ne
pouvais pas donner le je ne pouvais pas
leur permet de donner le meilleur d'eux
mêmes
parce que j'étais obligé de faire de la
discipline et des fois même sur des
actes d'agression de violence que je
n'imaginais pas en ce2 et du coup voilà
toute la classe en pâtissait et je
trouve ça dramatique parce qu'on
condamne en fait toute l'école toute la
classe au lieu de peut être aménagée
parce que on ne peut pas appliquer
exactement les mêmes procédures et la
même organisation sur tout le territoire
parce qu'il faut savoir s'adapter aux
spécificités de chacun si on veut
véritablement sortir par le haut et
cette excellence et pour revenir sur ce
que ce que vous disiez eric raby rapide
très rapidement
rabin on n'ira pas jusqu'au collège
nonnon mais de toute façon c'est avec la
réforme du collège fin c'était pas du
tout la priorité mais ça a déjà été
assez dit la réforme absolue c'est celle
de l'école primaire parce que on l'a
rappelé 16% d'illettrisme chez les
jeunes mais moi je peux vous dire que un
enfant sur quatre la majorité sont dans
les quartiers populaires et ça c'est
vraiment dramatique anton 6e son avenir
est déjà condamné mais je crois que
véritablement pour transmettre l'amour
de la france
il faut et c'est compliqué quand vous
vivez dans du béton et que vous ne
sortez pas de ces zones là il faut
qu'ils aient un rapport charnel avec la
france et vous l'aviez rappelé tout à
l'heure il faut qu'ils touchent cette
histoire absolument il faut qu'ils
touchent cette histoire de france
il faut qu'ils touchent les monuments
historiques il faut qu'ils aillent
visiter les châteaux
il faut quand même il y une perception
du paysage veut dire quand un enfant n'a
jamais senti un champ de lavande ou non
n'a jamais traversé la france et ne ne
sait pas que la france est un pays
d'agriculture par exemple ne peut pas
percevoir toutes les l'excellence et la
magnifique cité de notre notre pays et
pareil pour pour ce qui est de même des
guerres des batailles et de
l'extraordinaire paysage diversité de
notre paysage
il faut véritablement créer un parcours
je crois un parcours pour certains parce
que tout le monde n'a pas besoin de
découvrir la france mais il faut pour
eux un merci de la france pour réussir
leur faire aimer ce pays
merci ayed pour la merci à yale pour la
pression
on est obligé de la deûle à limiter dans
le temps et sans transition on va passer
au troisième volet qui est inséré
professionnellement ça n'est pas le but
premier forcément de l'éducation mais
néanmoins c'est une démission et qu'elle
ne peut qu elle ne peut ignorer
certes elle doit donner les capacités
d'apprendre des capacités de s'adapter
mais aussi des capacités d'insertion
professionnelle pour témoigner nous
accueillons philippe ansel qui est
conseiller économique de la fondation
concorde et j'ai le souvenir d'un exposé
que vous nous aviez fait sur justement
les besoins économiques et qui ne
doivent pas totalement
prendre le pas sur le reste mais qui ne
peuvent être ignorées dans le cadre de
l'organisation de notre système éducatif
et puis laurence balas qui est une élue
municipale de lyon mais qui est ici en
tant qu'ambassadrice rhône alpes de la
fondation entreprendre
alors à vous de en cinq minutes je suis
désolé c'est très difficile à résumer
tout une action et tout un engagement
mais merci de le faire le plus
synthétiquement possible donc je vais
essayer de vous transmettre le point de
vue de l'économie sur l'éducation et
vous allez voir nous ne sommes pas si
barbare il ya beaucoup de convergences
ceci en cinq points d'abord il faut
avoir en tête que l'éducation un impact
déterminant sur l'économie faut vraiment
le rappeler ne serait-ce que la simple
question de l'orthographe
par exemple tout le monde pense qu'avec
le numérique il n'ya plus des cris on
n'écrit plus c'est complètement faux on
le les écrits qui transitent sur la
toile est partout et est multiplié par
10 avec la numérisation et l'orthographe
joue un rôle important dans ses écrits
par exemple il ya un expert de la vente
en ligne charme d'une combe qui nous dit
qu'une seule faute d'orthographe peut
faire baisser de diviser les ventes par
deux sur un site internet parce qu'on
n'a pas confiance
ils font des fautes donc c'est vraiment
et en ce moment c'est la hantise des
responsables d'entreprises l'orthographe
je dois le dire
si encore on peut considérer ça d'un
point de vue macroéconomique par en
particulier la maîtrise du français
enfin la maîtrise de la lecture
si on fait un petit calcul enfin nous
l'avons fait si on considère qu'il ya 80
milles illettrés qui seront chaque année
à la charge de la société à raison de
huit mille euros c'est vraiment un
chiffre minima puisque la la fondation
atd quart monde nous dit que ça coûte
entre 15000 et 8000 euros
ces quatre-vingt mille personnes à 8000
euros par an toute leur vie c'est une
dépense à l'avenir social en termes
d'allègement de charges de dead etc de
40 milliards d'euros 2 points de pib et
qui vont nourrir notre endettement est
donc quelque part qu'on met ses 40
milliards d'euros qui le coût de la non
qualité de l'enseignement du français à
l'école primaire
on le met en rapport avec le budget de
l'éducation nationale 2 65 milliards
d'euros on s'aperçoit qu'on est dans le
même ordre de grandeur
alors certains vont dire je vous
remettre 20 milliards d'euros comme ça
on divise par deux et c'est non à la
base c'est quand même une question de
méthode dans c'est pas une question de
moyens et les méthodes d'apprentissage
des français constitue donc à 1 ap de la
lecture constitue un enjeu macro
économiques fondamentales bon
sous-estiment le deuxième point c'est le
la responsabilité de la dégradation de
notre système éducatif dans notre panne
économique
il faut savoir que la france est en
panne enfin je sais pas si vous en avez
conscience
un seul chiffre nous produisons moins de
biens manufacturés qu'en 1996
or notre consommation de ces biens c'est
à dire tout ce que nous avons sur les
tables les chaises etc
les vêtements a augmenté de 60% depuis
cette date c'est à dire qu'en fait notre
pays consomme mais ne produit plus et
ils se financent à crédit alors
évidemment ça n'aura qu'un temps pour
vous dire par exemple sur moi il n'ya
que ses lunettes qui ont été fabriqués
en france
mais c'est un acte militant bien sûr
alors je n'aurai pas la cruauté de vous
rappeler nos places dans les classements
internationaux mais qui sont extrêmement
mauvais mais nous avons fait une étude
assez intéressante nous avons regardé
dans la zone euro parce que c'est des
pays comparables
les pays qui avaient augmenté leur
production manufacturière depuis 2000 et
ce qui qu'il avait réduites et il ya une
corrélation parfaite avec le niveau de
l'éducation dans les classements pisa et
pjak
c'est à dire que les pays qui ont les
meilleurs scores qu'ils aillent pjak
augmenter leur production manufacturière
les pays qui ont les plus mauvais scores
ont baissé leur production
manufacturière
malheureusement nous ne sommes pas dans
la bonne catégorie nous sommes dans les
pays qui ont baissé leur production
manufacturière pour illustrer sa alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire comme on a un
mauvais
niveau d'éducation dans les entreprises
on n'arrive pas utiliser les équipements
les plus performants
par exemple vous savez on vous l'a
certainement dit l'avenir était à la
robotisation bain co regarde les
chiffres de la robotisation pour 1000
emplois dans le secteur manufacturier la
france est le pays le moins robotisée ya
07 robots pour 1000 emplois 2,4 en
allemagne ça ne vous étonnera pas mais
1,3 en espagne en italie
donc on est vraiment le pays qui ne
s'est le moins bien utiliser les moyens
de production les plus modernes donc
c'est extrêmement inquiétant et en amont
c'est vraiment notre id notre régression
éducative qui est à la base de cette
régression productive alors troisième
point je crois qu'il faut avoir en tête
que notre économie va être bouleversé
par tout un bouquet de rupture
technologique on n'a pas le temps de les
énumérer
mais ce qui va se passer c'est qu'on va
avoir une rupture entre d'un côté la
création de valeur c'est à dire les
entreprises qui vont être insérées dans
les échanges internationaux et la
création d'emplois dans l'économie
domestique mais ceux qui financent
l'économie c'est les entreprises inséré
dans l'est via dans les échanges
internationaux
et ça ça va dépendre d'un nombre réduit
de gens de haut niveau de scientifiques
d'entrepreneurs je pense qu'on en
parlera tout à l'heure et de
travailleurs extrêmement qualifiés par
contre les emplois les plus vulnérables
c'est les emplois moyens c'est un peu la
spécialité française 1 par exemple
tyler cohen qui dit la moyenne études
moyennes joe moye un salarié moyen c'est
fini c'est à dire tous les emplois un
peu bureaucratique moyens qu'on a créés
dans l'administration
ce sont ces emplois qui sont appelées à
disparaître alors quelles sont les
conséquences en termes d'éducation de
formation d'abord s'était dit il faut
que la france renoue avec l'élitisme
républicain c'est à dire c'est vraiment
les gens de très haut niveau qui vont
nous qui vont porter nos entreprises les
amener à les aider à rayonner sur les
marchés internationaux
donc il faut absolument qu'on produise à
nouveau une élite scientifique et
technique et malheureusement qui est en
régression
donc il faut en effet qu'on retrouve
notre niveau en mathématiques
je crois qu'il faut citer les scores
pisa en 2000 en pizza mathématiques on
était à 517 en 2012 on est à 495 qu'on
sait qu'on figurait parmi les deux
leaders mathématiques puisqu'on a eu
autant de médailles fields que les
américains c'était vraiment notre point
fort que les mathématiques c'est ça qui
rythme toute l'économie du le numérique
la biologie la physique l'informatique
donc c'est extrêmement inquiétant il
faut vraiment qu'on se remette au
travail dans le domaine des
mathématiques
dernier point qu'est ce que veut dire
qu'est ce que signifie cette ce bouquet
de rupture technologique mais je crois
qu'il ya quelque chose qui est
intéressant je crois que vous allez
peut-être surpris ce site et les travaux
de hannut chèque et wiesmann des
chercheurs de l' ocde qui ont mis en
évidence que ce qui compte c'est pas la
durée des études mais c'est la qualité
des études
c'est à dire quand il regarde la
corrélation entre la croissance
économique et le niveau pisa il ya une
corrélation évidente c'est à dire plus
les gens sont bien formés à 15 en plus
le pays connaît une bonne croissance
économique
par contre vous pouvez avoir un mauvais
niveau et faire pour suivre vos
étudiants des études jusqu'à 30 ans ça
ne rapporte rien donc c'est vraiment
extrêmement frappant corrélation 0
qu'est-ce que ça pour comment ça
s'explique dans cette période de
mutation technologique
il faut avoir en tête que 50 % des
emplois en 2030 n'ont pas encore été
inventé donc ce qui compte c'est d'avoir
des gens qui ont vraiment acquis les
fondamentaux en français en
mathématiques
enfin vraiment lorsque ce dont a parlé
le socle des savoirs fondamentaux
c'est ça qui compte parce que ça leur
permettra d'intégrer les ruptures
technologiques une année enfin on fait
on travaille beaucoup en ce moment sur
les nouvelles technologies bon juste je
vais citer par exemple le domaine du
maraîchage parce que moi j'aime beaucoup
les légumes c'est un sujet qui
m'intéresse beaucoup
nous avons une start up française qui
s'appelle nahio qui en train de mettre
sur le marché avec beaucoup de succès
des robots de désherbage est vraiment
c'est en plein boom la vienne 2
quinze jours ils ont fait une levée de
fonds de plusieurs millions d'euros
qu'est ce que ça veut dire se dire que
le maraîcher il va falloir qu'il fasse à
peu près marché des robots pour pour
s'occuper
oui donc pour cela il a besoin d'un bon
bagage quand même il faut qu'il regarde
comment ça marche et c'est donc donc
c'est extrêmement important
qu'est ce que ça veut dire je pense
qu'il faut d'un côté donc on remettra et
je vais terminer à l'honneur le mérite
républicain et avoir vraiment dé
produire à nouveau des élites et puis le
côté probablement il faudra évoluer vers
a su un système couplant un niveau de
connaissances élevé peut-être une entrée
assez rapide sur le marché du travail
mais la possibilité de reprendre des
formations voilà mais là je rêve
merci merci
mais c'est vrai que la formation toute
la formation continue la formation tout
au long de la vie c'est aussi un dea
des axes importants de réussite pour
terminer la fondation entreprendre de
laurence leur antre menace merci
dominique je vais je vais rebondir sur
ce que vous avez dit la plupart des
métiers que les jeunes qui sont dans
l'enseignement aujourd'hui connaîtront
n'existe pas aujourd'hui et j'en veux
pour témoignage même en hier encore
j'étais dans un débat avec des
entrepreneurs et la patronne d'une
grande banque à lyon a dit moi je moi
même je ne sais pas ce que sera la
banque dans cinq ans donc c'est vraiment
un très court terme donc ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui pour nos jeunes c'est qu'ils
soient capables de s'adapter de
s'adapter à un environnement qui change
d'être agile c'est un mot qu'on entend
beaucoup en ce moment d'être curieux et
de pouvoir être prêt à toutes les
situations
donc c'est un petit peu ce qu'on essaie
de faire à la fondation entreprendre qui
est une fondation qui est dédié à
diffuser la culture entrepreneuriale
dans notre pays
donc nous le faisons ça c'est pas le
sujet aujourd'hui en accompagnant des
créateurs d'entreprise
et puis aussi en sensibilisant les
jeunes à la culture d'entreprendre
entreprendre pour nous ça veut pas dire
forcément créer son entreprise c'est
évident que tous les jeunes ne vont pas
être demain chefs d'entreprise mais
entreprendre ça veut surtout dire
entreprendre sa vie c'est avoir un
projet pouvoir se projeter dans cet
avenir qui est un peu incertain alors
c'est à la fois anxiogène mais c'est
aussi très positif est source
d'opportunités
il ya des tas de nouveaux métiers de
nouvelles entreprises qui vont naître
donc il faut préparer les jeunes à ça et
parfois même dans des quartiers où ils
ont moins de chances moins de deux
modèles dans lequel se projeter et bien
leur faire passer ce discours lors dire
oui un avenir est possible pour vous si
vous en avez vraiment la volonté vous
allez pouvoir le faire et on vous montre
des exemples de gens qui vous ressemble
qui ont fait ça et qu'ils ont fait ce
parcours et ça c'est quelque chose de
très important
on a beaucoup insisté ce matin sur le
socle de compétences la culture à
transmettre les enseignements
fondamentaux mais je pense qu'il faut
aussi les illustrés par des choses plus
concrètes et c'est ce qu'on essaye de
faire avec des associations que nous
soutenons à la fondation entreprendre
je vais vous donner quelques exemples il
ya une association qui s'appelle par
exemple 100 1000 entrepreneurs ce sont
des entrepreneurs ou des cadres par
forcément des chefs d'entreprise insiste
là-dessus ce qu'on appelle aussi des
intrapreneurs qui vont témoigner
échanger pendant une matinée avec des
jeunes leur expliquer leur propre
parcours comment ils en sont arrivés là
ce que ça a demandé qu'est ce que ça
implique comment ça se passe et puis
échangé avec les élèves et ça donne
toujours lieu à des échanges très
intéressants
ce n'est pas un enseignant qui est là
dans la classe et c'est quelqu'un du
monde
j'allais dire de la vie réelle mais bon
ça c'est un peu cliché de dire ça mais
en tout cas qui vient d'ailleurs et qui
a un discours différent et les
enseignants qui font venir ces
entrepreneurs sont toujours enfin dans
l'ensemble généralement très satisfait
parce qu'ils voient certains élèves qui
vont se révéler dans cette position
différente ce moment des changes
différent de témoignages avec des
entrepreneurs est pour certains élèves
qui ont des difficultés des difficultés
de français des difficultés
d'apprentissage
eh bien il va y avoir des déblocages qui
vont se faire et peut-être qu'après et
bien cet élève tel ou tel élève sera
plus attentif à divers renseignements et
pourra se projeter pourra retrouver un
sens au fait qu'il est à l'école
pourquoi je suis à l'école pourquoi je
suis au collège pourquoi chez au lycée à
quoi ça va m'amener et ben ça va l'aider
peut-être à se projeter dans le futur
d'autres associations comme entreprendre
pour apprendre
nous menons des projets miniers
entreprises pendant une année sous
l'égide d'un enseignant et puis d'un
entrepreneur et bien des élèves une
classe va travailler ensemble pour
construire une véritable petite
entreprise ils vont définir un projet un
produit
organiser leur entreprise avec un patron
un directeur des ressources humaines
ouvrir un compte en banque enfin passer
par toutes ces étapes et ce travail
collectif va les souder les faire
réfléchir différemment leur faire encore
une fois envisager les apprentissages de
manière différente et c'est toujours
très positif les les retours qu'on a que
ce soit des élèves des enseignants puis
des chefs d'entreprise qui témoigne sont
toujours très positif donc nous nous
pensons que ce genre d'expérience est
vraiment important c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses dans l'école dans
l'éducation des choses fondamentales à
enseigner mais il faut aussi cette porte
ouverte sur l'avenir le monde de
l'entreprise et les associations vous il
ya un certain nombre d'associations qui
font un travail formidable j'oubliais
dire que on s'adresse pas seulement aux
jeunes qui sont scolarisés mais les
décrocheurs aussi il ya des expériences
très intéressante qui se font autour de
la notion d'entreprise autour de leur
passion on leur fait imaginer lors de
l'entreprise qu'il pourrait créer
donc ça c'est des choses qui sont
vraiment importante pour nous et qui
doivent être inscrits dans le parcours
de l'éducation aujourd'hui la fondation
se sont beaucoup nous avons des
associations qui travaillent
bénévolement à la demande des
enseignants mais ça n'est pas
véritablement un corps inscrit dans un
parcours et nous avons l'année dernière
à compas sensibiliser 80 mille jeunes ce
qui est beaucoup mais ce qui est rien
par rapport aux 6 millions de jeunes qui
pourraient être sensibilisés de cette
façon donc il faut maintenant dans les
propositions qu'on fait c'est de dire
qu'il faudrait arriver à inscrire
vraiment des horaires précis dans le
déroulement du collège du lycée parce
que il ya eu une réflexion qui est fait
il ya quand même beaucoup de choses qui
ont été faites notamment depuis 2013
avec l'éducation nationale la fondation
a participé aux débats aux travaux qui
ont été faits mais tant qu'il n'y a pas
quelque chose d' inscrire durablement un
créneau horaire
c'était un peu le cas pour le parcours
dp3 qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure mais
qui va disparaître avec la réforme la
mise en place de la réforme donc ça
c'est bien dommage c'était peut-être le
seul créneau qui était défini donc ce
que nous demandons aujourd'hui est ce
qu'il faudrait arriver à faire c'est
qu'il y ait des créneaux horaires
définis un budget débloqué alors petit 1
je vous rassure parce que par exemple
nous avons calculé que pour sensibiliser
tous les jeunes qui sont
dans le lycée professionnel ça coûterait
20 millions d'euros pour qu'ils aient
tous accès à un projet de mini
entreprises
donc voila et puis le dernier le dernier
sujet très important c'est la
sensibilisation des enseignants et il
faut mettre des outils à la disposition
des enseignants les associations on
travaille et on construit des catalogues
des propositions mais il ya tout un
travail aussi d'éducation auprès des
enseignants très peu sont ont été
confrontés au monde de l'entreprise et
je dirais même et c'est vraiment
peut-être le plus inquiétant que au
niveau du lycée les enseignants
d'économies sont les plus réfractaires
et c'est assez significatif des travaux
à faire des progrès à faire
les plus réfractaires à l'entrée du
monde de l'entreprise dans l'école
donc là il ya beaucoup de choses à faire
mais voilà les propositions que nous
pouvons faire merci merci laurence merci
à vous si ce nous avons dans cette table
ronde essayer de vous faire passer
beaucoup de rats de vous proposer
beaucoup de témoignages et de faire
passer de nombreux un message vous
l'avez compris la réussite de l'élève va
tout moment de sa vie mais aussi quels
que soient son environnement et quel que
soit son histoire est une belle ambition
voilà merci pour votre attention